Paris
[Musique]
Porte de l'activité qu'il pratique Mendy
Lévy 18 ans aime bien prendre en photo
et publier sur les réseaux sociaux
images de Luis arbre à son meilleur
profil
ces photos sur Instagram constituent
peut-être pour lui la preuve tangible
qui n'est plus prisonnier des lève-tard
une secte où il a passé les 15 premières
années de sa vie
[Musique]
la secte juive les stores à faire notre
rebondissements dans l'affaire de la
secte juive livescore le sort des
enfants de la secte or
la saga des enfants de la secte les
stars a fait la manchette pendant des
années le groupe s'est installé à
Sainte-Agathe-des-Monts le plus loin
possible des familles israéliennes des
adeptes inquiète pour leurs enfants et
leurs petits-enfants qui vivait selon
les enseignements de leur gourou
excentrique est autoritaire
[Musique]
Mandy est né ici c'est le lieu où il a
passé son enfance une enfance peuplée de
très mauvais souvenirs
[Musique]
de novembre 2013
le Québec demande alors à l'Ontario de
ramener sur tes enfants sur son
territoire Meylan Tariot refuse les 13
jeunes vont rester en l'Ontario ils ne
seront pas placer dans les familles
d'accueil au Québec car cela risquerait
de les perturber davantage selon la juge
pendant ses tractations les les stores
prépare une nouvelle fuite destination
Guatemala
et ça
ne s'arrête pas la
circonstance et puis en novembre 2021 du
groupe sans condamné aux États-Unis pour
kidnapping il voulait ramener au
Guatemala des enfants de dissidente pour
les mariés de force mais si on voulait
le forcer à se marier il avait 14 ans
mais l'adolescent et chaque phrase
destin il réussi à déjouer la vigilance
des leader de la secte équipe de
Guatemala
[Musique]
ils lui ont tout montrer car Mandy
arrivé non seulement du Guatemala mais
surtout d'une autre planète hélas avait
rien sur le monde et on savait pas que
il y en a une planète nous sommes très
heureux qu'il est avec nous et qu'il est
en sécurité mais il a 7 enfants de sa
famille qui sont là-bas encore qu'ils
ont dure le même
abuse
le souvenir de ses frères et soeur c'est
peut-être l'image qui hante encore le
regard de
[Musique]